when you two both heard about the film
six years did you have a gut feeling
that you were going to get the part huh
I knew I wanted it I didn't know if I
would get I don't think you can ever
know if you're gonna get it but I know I
had a great my meet my first meeting was
a Skype session with a half I'd elbow
the director in March applause and the
Skype went well I thought they loved me
I thought I could charm them a little
bit so I had high hopes yeah I had the
exact same experience I read it and I
was like I could definitely really play
this part I want it and then after the
Skype I was like this sounds great hope
I get it
because I imagine that even though you
have a great feeling there's been other
times when you haven't gotten
something's and that's a typical thing
for actors like there sometimes it's the
worst audition they end up getting and
they and they love you and you're like
okay no idea what I did but I'll try you
it again yeah or you think you killed it
and you know yeah I tried so bad
crying when do you start learning your
lines for your characters from Ellen Dan
well for six years there was a lot of
improv yeah it's a mostly improvised
movie so we couldn't really try to yeah
there weren't a lot of lines to learn
there's more about understanding of
circumstances and wearing you know where
the characters are at that moment where
they're just coming from and stuff like
that so did Hannah and Mark then have
like another in-person session where
they said okay this is the angle that
everybody's taking um I mean we both got
off of the part right after the Skype
session yes and then um during like
pre-production stuff Hannah Ben and I we
all hung out and did bonding trips and
really worked on discussing the
characters in the story in the arcs and
where they are like emotion in the
scenes and yeah that's really what
helped yeah and we did that like four
months or five months I don't know we
did it like two months it was a couple
few months under there yeah it was a it
was a good amount of time beforehand so
we we knew we're where we should be at
by the time we got to Austin would it
tell us about these bonding trips if you
can like wait what happens what is it
you guys telling deep dark secrets so
you kind of get like this trust thing or
what's going on
uh I mean if we're telling DVR secrets I
think it kind of naturally happens yeah
so it's not like all right let's sit
down we're having a session now tell me
Dylan what's the bottom of your heart um
it was like we just uh I didn't know
what to expect I had never done a
bonding or whatever retreat whatever you
just there's a little nerve-wracking
right I was nervous
yeah it's like are we gonna bond I'm
like let's just hang out and yeah figure
out the story we talked about the
characters in the script and we watched
some movies that were sort of reference
points and got to know each other a
little bit before yours are I brought my
guitar yeah it was fun so no trust Falls
or anything no don't even stop okay
listen we're really just hanging out
yeah okay cool how much time then do you
normally spend on the character before I
know you're doing this bonding trip and
everything but then did you then
separate and say well I'm gonna really
think about who these people are yeah I
mean a lot of it happens and when we
finally flat when we find flew out to
Austin we still had a couple days before
we started shooting and you know like
during the wardrobe fittings and all
about you're still discussing the
characters you can discussing things and
I mean I spent time looking at the
script beforehand but you can only do so
much prep work you know especially on
such an improv based movie like I know
we knew the general motion so it was
about 20 minutes before each scene where
Hannah would come to us and we'd be like
okay so this is kind of what we needed
information we need to get across on the
scene and here's like a line or two in
case you can't think of anything and
then she kind of just let us loose yeah
I think it's totally project dependent
like certain characters demand a certain
type of preparation if you're going to
change your physicality or your voice or
something like that and other and
sometimes you have a lot of time rare
and sometimes you just don't sometimes
you only have a week or something so it
just depends now I know there were
several emotional scenes in the phone
without giving away too much which do
you feel was the most difficult for your
character and maybe even for both of you
personally
so we're served very intense yeah
relationship moments there I'm sure many
people can relate to that have been won
hopefully not too many of them but yeah
but yeah there were some definite it's
dark moments in Edward there certain
time I've seen at the party where Mel
has a discovery moment which leads to
some conflicts was a difficult for the
character difficult for me it was a
really tough camera shot too because
there's a really lot of long takes in
that one and a lot of movement so that
was like another challenge but so that
was a really challenging one in there
for one of the most fun to shoot yeah
it's hard when it's not only physically
yeah exhausting you know like it's a bit
we had to move around a lot but also
emotionally exhausting you put those two
together over shooting till like 3:00
a.m. and you realize where the time goes
and you're just so tired yeah we were
after that scene we were so like drain
yeah but then you all saw them not you
just saw so proud you have a moment of
accomplishment okay I feel like we got
it yeah yeah that was an excellent scene
well we won't give away any more yeah so
that people can yeah but I can see why
you would be drained they're not seen
when are you two most nervous on a film
set
ah you just the first day I mean I I
just love once like the first couple
days are over with and you're in the
descent whatever kind of routine it is
because no movie has a real routine
because everything's always up in here
and changing but the first day you just
want to just want to do well and make
sure if you think you're preparing
you're ready and you know the character
but you just never know how the day's
gonna go first day for me yeah first day
of school James yeah I don't get nervous
when I make a film no I feel like really
relaxation is like the key to good work
in a lot of ways so I've gotten good at
just going into it interesting so you
like it's not where you're like I'm not
sure how the mood of the sets going to
be you're just like whatever
hopefully I know by the time I get there
I've met some people and gotten the vibe
and feel comfortable I guess when I
might be nervous on a set is when things
start to
go poorly but I haven't had too many of
those experiences then you think back to
some of your first performances and
mistakes in your mind
that you feel that you were hard on
yourselves for that you then corrected
and what were they hmm I mean watching
watching stuff from you I mean I've been
acting for four and a half years now I'm
watching so my first stuff I remember
thinking at the time because especially
the movies you shoot it and then you
don't get to see it until like a year
more later you know and you've grown and
changed so much in that time so watching
it you're like sometimes I think oh why
did I why did I convey that emotion or
why'd I make that face and you're
looking at it but you're nitpicking
things and at the time I believe I did
the best I could you know and it's just
I think it's just slight unconscious
things of just learning to try and you
know put all the motions there and have
stuff beyond the eyes and really know
that there's a process going on yeah I
find that like most of the learning
happens in the process of making the
film and that I can't I usually watch a
film or anything that I've made like
maybe one time and then sort of put it
away I think that the general thing as
an actor as a young actor is like you
want to lean into those emotions the big
emotions in a project in the arc of a
character and I think that's something
I've learned over the years is maybe to
avoid leaning into those emotions too
much we do have excellent like physical
very like in the uncomfortable scenes I
like how there's like sometimes silence
but with the body language or a grimace
or something you can definitely see it
so was that something that you studied
within yourself cuz I know some actors
won't watch themselves and they're just
so opposed to it yeah I mean I agree
with you Ben I'd like to watch it one or
two times and and that's it because then
you start nitpicking and I don't want to
remember a movie for you know mine
securities I'll remember it for what my
first impression was I think that
natural behavior really came out of the
improvisational way that the film was
made so yeah and in terms of watching
playback and stuff like that and like
adding a grimace or something you know
small things like that hi
I'm not into that I think the only time
in naturally first yeah absolutely I
love to silences because you can say so
much without saying words that's the
beauty of cinemas you can be
expositional without dialogue yeah yeah
how many takes did you have before most
scenes for six years I know you said it
was sometimes you were amongst the wall
timeline yeah I don't know ah yeah I
mean we definitely did a fair amount of
takes of stuff because it was
improvisational and a really I mean I
don't know Agatha I think somewhere
between four and six was like a fair
number from the changed camera angles or
something yeah it wasn't Kubrick levels
of text was there was no scene with like
a hundred and twenty ten no talks about
no money for that
it was definitely we we got a lot of
takes though we did a lot of different
things than every every take so there's
a lot yeah when you're acting in a scene
how much are you thinking about blocking
and where the camera is and then what do
you know what you're going to do next
how much in conscious of that ah it's
great when you don't have to be
conscious of blocking that was great so
in Hanna's maybe we didn't have to be
aware too much
I mean Han would be like okay cameras
probably be in this general area but she
still let us move and the camera would
move with us exactly um it's all about
following what we were doing with this
film which is great I like to really
think about that stuff when we're
rehearsing because that's when you sort
of with this film is less locked in but
when you do the rehearsal which is right
before you shoot it that's when you
start to lock yourself into things so I
really think about it a lot then and
then I try to totally forget about it
yeah I mean it sometimes it's hard I
remember there was a I was shooting
season 1 of American Horror Story on the
pilot there was this one
there's one moment where I walk in and
I'm supposed to walk a certain way or
not slam my feet I don't remember and I
write before they would say action I
would think okay pick up your feet don't
don't make that don't make that sound
that's bothering the sound Department
and every time five times room I
completely forgot as soon as they said
actually it's hard to think about the
real life at the same time when you're
like okay and in the character I'm
playing this person now and literally I
even though I just reminded myself like
ten seconds before they said action I
couldn't remember to pick up my feet a
certain way yeah it can be hard
sometimes but what are the most
important things that you have to figure
out for a character in general like when
you're digesting who you're playing even
if it's improv what what are some of I
mean they say like what the person's
like truth is or what their core motives
are what is it that you're figuring out
about your character to really like
drive it I have no idea it's kind of
just
I don't know I don't know what the
specific is I just try and figure them
out you know I definitely want to
understand the story that the director
wants to tell and try and the writer as
well try and figure out exactly what
that story is
but again it's so dependent on the
project there's so many different ways
into a character and I think it's really
depending on the script and the director